ah j'aime bien vous parlez de produits
pour la maison et aujourd'hui je vous
parle de ce produit là où ce produit là
c'est un aspirateur connectés de la
marque robot rock alors ce qu'on va
faire c'est que je vais vous l'ouvrir je
vais vous le montrer c'est un tout
nouveau produit la référence c'est le s7
et le s est il est assez intéressant
parce qu'il ya une belle évolution par
rapport à la génération précédente
j'aime bien vous parlez de maison
connectée de voir comment solution de la
vie avec différents produits pour cela
que je viens vous présenter ce produit
là c'est une vidéo qui a réalisé
aujourd'hui en partenariat avec robot
rock c'est un grand classique / europe
le câble d'alimentation la notice
adducteurs pia pour venir nettoyer on va
arriver en dessous directement sur le
nouveau produit on à la petite base pour
venir le poser
je vais l'installer je vais l'essayer je
vous montrais toutes les nouveautés vous
avez le bac qui est juste là le filtre à
changer de place
ah oui c'est marrant c'est à dire se
positionner comme ça là je vois qu'il ya
une toute nouvelle brosse là et puis
vous avez plein de capteurs tous les
côtés vous avez un laser sur le dessus
qui lui permet de cartographier votre
maison et donc je le prends je
m'installe je le teste même coup de clap
pour vous ça va durer rien du tout pour
moi c'est le temps d'installer
d'apprendre à le connaître et je vais
mortoire et ça c'est bien
[Musique]
voilà alors bon il est temps de vous
donner mon retour sur ce produit je sais
pas si vous le savez mais je vous ai
parlé plusieurs fois d'aspirateurs
connectés de maison connectée bien
évidemment et d'aspirateurs connectés en
particulier et notamment de la marque
rob horne ce produit là continuent à
montrer l'évolution de robot rock sur
l'idée du nettoyage intelligents et
connectés à la maison et c'est ça qui va
venir l'intéressé pas que le truc qui va
chemin bien c'est au niveau de la brosse
avant vous aviez une brosse à poils
l'inconvénient qu'on retrouvait au bout
d'un moment à l'utilisation sur la
brosse à poils c'est que si vous avez
des poils ou des cheveux un petit peu
long que les antillais et bien ça vous
l'abîmé et ça pouvait venir nuire à
l'expérience de balayage là vous avez
tout un système en caoutchouc qui vient
lieu capter qui est plus un qui va pas
s'user en tout cas comme l'autre bros
donc ça c'est la première nouveauté
matérielle je dirais la deuxième
nouveauté vous allez retrouver là en
fait ici vous avez une vibration avec
une technologie sonic pour optimiser le
nettoyage ce qui fait que s'il arrive
sur une vieille tâches que vous avez
laissé une tache de café ou je ne sais
quoi et bien il n'est d'autre a très
facilement il se retrouve un truc
vachement bien et savent où le retrouver
ici
lorsqu ils nettoient la serpillière et
en bas et lorsqu'ils arrivent sur un
tapis il se lève on le voit très
clairement il se lève pour ne pas venir
mouiller le tapis et vous allez voir un
boost d'aspiration au moment où il va
arriver sur le tapis
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve ça intéressant l'idée de
ce produit qui est intelligent avec ses
différents capteurs qui va être en
mesure en capacité de reconnaître un
tapis alors déjà il savait reconnaître
le vide ce qui fait que lorsqu'il
arrivait sur une surface on d'escalier
du compagnie bien ils se jetaient pas
c'était bien mais vous pouvez aller
encore plus loin je vais vous montrer
dans votre application dans quelques
instants c'est si vous voulez pas par
exemple qui viennent nettoyer arbitres
parce qu'il sait les reconnaître
eh bien il peut ne pas venir nettoyer
pour l'avenir le décoller légèrement
pour venir nettoyer sous tapis
[Musique]
mais le plus intéressant là dedans c'est
quand même de venir voir ce qui se passe
directement dans l'application parce que
oui parce qu'on parle ici bien
évidemment d'objets connectés comme on
parle d'objets connectés on parle
d'applications à venir voir un petit peu
ce qui se passe directement ici alors
regardez ça c'est votre application
l'application elle se situe justement
c'est votre application robot rock vous
ne téléchargez sur radio 1 c'est sur
android très très facilement vous
arrivez vous avez la liste de vos
inspirateur alors moi ici j'en ai deux
wild sexe et le modèle que j'essaye
actuellement dans les paramètres de -7
je vois déjà la dernière vonn qui a
nettoyé lui fallait étudier cette zone
là tout à l'heure je vois qu'il me reste
100% de batterie et je vois que ce
dernier nettoyage a duré 17 minutes et
ensuite j'ai la cartographie ça c'est un
truc que j'aime vraiment que son super
intéressante qui vient cartographier la
maison grâce à son laser et connaît les
pièces et reconnaît les murs et surtout
qu intéressante que lorsqu'il vient
toucher une zone par exemple voyez il
touche tac ça décale quelques laser qui
reconnaît les murs il se décale il se
remet en place
[Musique]
si vous voulez venir ensuite modifier
votre carte vous avez aussi un petit
truc vous venez clic et vous pouvez
définir des zones où vous ne voulez pas
qu'ils aillent selon lenovo zone
je peux créer un mur invisible je peux
créer une zone je peux créer un endroit
ne va pas venir nettoyer juste qu'ils
viennent inspiré bien c'est complètement
possible peut par exemple regarder la
créer un petit mur que je viens déplacés
par exemple cjb je veux pas que tu fais
dans cette pièce là haut up la voyez je
mets un petit muret l'a clairement ici
il ira pas bon et si c'est pas le but je
peux aussi lui dire bah tiens cette zone
là par exemple ce périmètre là je veux
pas qu'il fasse je veux pas que tu lis
aussi une possibilité ce n'est pas le
cas et je prévenir le diabète 1 ici par
exemple dans cette zone
je ne veux pas que tu nettoies jeu juste
que tu aspires donc ici tu mettras pado
je peux également venir paramétrer un
mes pièces je peux venir allaient
fusionner entre elles je peux me dire
les diviser je peux dire changer les
noms si je souhaite par exemple
subdiviser ma pièce de vie avec un salon
salle à manger une cuisine bien que ce
soit ouvert et bien je peux le faire ça
c'est plutôt intéressant comme ça que
faire du nettoyage sélectif va nettoyer
la cuisine ne va pas nettoyé le salon
bon je n'ai pas fait ici
mais si je souhaite je peux le faire je
peux également venir personnalisés je
souhaite apparaître dans la deuxième
chambre et bien je peux dire ben tiens
tu va nettoyer tout doucement ou alors
moyens carrément turbo ou alors au
maximum pour l'aspiration et pareil pour
l'intensité de l'eau je peux lui dire tu
me mets pas d'eau ou alors tourner un
tout petit peu pour bien nettoyer tu vas
un peu plus ou alors là carrément on
voit de la flotte à fond faut vraiment
être voyez ça et pareil pour le chemin
de nettoyage peut dire soit tu fais un
nettoyage de standards faut tout faire
nettoyage en profondeur je peux
également bien créer des séquences arras
est aussi intéressant je vais le dire
qu'il va venir d'abord me nettoyer la
pièce de vie ensuite le hall ensuite la
chambre ensuite l'autre chambre tu
finiras avec les wc et la salle de bain
je lui mets une séquence je lui mets un
ordre comme je souhaite en fonction de
la superficie de votre maison il se peut
qu'il ait pas assez de batteries pour
tous venir nettoyer à ce moment là ce
qui va faire c'est qui va commencer le
voyage quand il aura plus beaucoup de
batteries va en retourne à sa station de
charge et hilton qui sera rechargée à
80%
il va reprendre les toits y avait au
sein d'êta arrêtés et la même manière je
peux venir personnalisés l'aspiration et
l'eau de façon globale sur l'ensemble de
mon nettoyage comme je voulais montrer
tout à l'heure vous voyez c'est très
facile de faire ça comme ça une fois que
je suis ici je peux soit l'envoyer sur
le dock aller se recharger
soit qu'ils viennent de faire un
nettoyage une fois que sur la fonction
full complète et même faire toute la
maison sinon je peux sélectionner des
pièces de la même manière je dis tu va
nettoyer par exemple la pièce de vie où
je devais nettoyer la chambre je peux
choisir pièce par pièce en lui disant tu
me fais soit 1,6 soit de cycle soi-même
trois cycles comme ça va vraiment de
faire un nettoyage en profondeur il la
même manière par zone
je veux définir une zone par exemple
j'ai renversé du café dans la cuisine
juste dans cette zone là gens vont
il me les toits et c'est aussi très
pratique
[Musique]
alors après six prêtres petits
paramètres que je trouve vraiment
intéressant notamment moi aussi je vois
tous les paramètres qui sont un peu
classique le nom du robot l'indicateur
lettre qui est sur le dessus
j'ai un mot de sécurité pour les enfants
qui va venir désactiver les boutons je
peux lui dire un mode aussi ne pas
déranger veux pas qu'ils passent
l'aspirateur entre 19 heures et 9 heures
du matin notamment le week-end et en
plus casse intéressant c'est que j'ai
aussi des cartes sur plusieurs niveaux
alors soit vous avez un seul étage soit
vous avez plusieurs étages
si vous avez plusieurs étages il va
enregistrer différente car vous n'avez
qu'à l'opposé la première fois il à
venir scanner étage par étage pour thabo
avenir l'envoyer ou vous voulez bien
évidemment c'est à vous de le monter
dans les étages parce qu'encore pour
l'instant il n'est pas capable de monter
les étages tout seul peut-être que ça
arrivera un jour
allez savoir tous les paramètres au
niveau de votre tapis pour venir boost
au niveau du tapis le premier mode il va
venir nettoyer les tapis et lorsqu'il
arrive sur le tapis
il vient relever là sa fille à coups
qu'elle ne vienne pas affronter ça c'est
vachement bien le deuxième mode que vous
avez juste en dessous il va éviter les
tapis il ne va pas relever vallée
contourner il va même devenir les
pousser pour qu'il se relève et venir
nettoyer dessous ça c'est plutôt pas mal
ou alors vous venez carrément ignoré
c'est à dire que lui va arriver avec la
serpillière sur les tapis bon c'est pas
forcément que je vous conseille la voie
durant bobrow si moi je les vis en
france et bien évidemment vous pouvez
venir programmée alors moi je n'ai pas
fait mais si vous souhaitez par exemple
lui dire le lundi le mercredi et le
vendredi de la nettoyer la cuisine
tu vas me faire tous les jours la
chambre tu vas me faire deux fois par
semaine la pièce de vie je peux vraiment
me reparamétrer en faisant à quelle
heure et doit y aller on règle bien
évidemment la puissance d'aspiration et
bien évidemment une fois de plus le
débit d'eau donc ça c'est cool je peux
également venir l'envoyer un point
précis si je souhaite m'amuse à venir
piloter directement comme ça depuis mon
application soit avec des boutons soit
avec un petit joystick je vais retrouver
l'historique de mai dernier nettoyage
bord autrement maintenant s'il va me
dire par exemple est-ce que je dois
changer à mon fils que je dois changer
ma brosse latérale ma brosse principal
est ce que je dois nettoyer les capteurs
je mens exactement où j'en suis donc ça
c'est plutôt pas mal aussi
je peux venir contacter le service
client et si si j'ai besoin j'ai un
petit manuel d'utilisation à toutes les
informations et bien évidemment je peux
me remettre à jour si je souhaite moi il
est à jour pour l'instant
donc ça c'est plutôt bien moi ce que
j'aime bien ici c'est tout le côté
applicatif vous venez le piloter très
facilement depuis votre smartphone ios
android ça s'est vraiment bien c'est
vraiment le gros point positif quant à
me retrouver avec cet aspirateur robot
c'est la connectivité c'est le fait
qu'il va vous simplifier la vie vous
n'avez qu'à le programme et vous venez
juste mettre de l'eau vous le retirez
vous nettoyez votre bac avec les
cochonneries qu'il aspire à l'intérieur
et c'est tout avec la technologie sony
vous avez plus de 3000 vibrations par
minute donc robot rock continue à
évoluer continue à se réinventer à l'est
loin au niveau de ces aspirateurs
connecté au delà de l'aspirateur au delà
du côté nettoyage mais ce qui
m'intéresse une fois plus c'est vraiment
le côté connectés voir comment on arrive
à utiliser les technologies connecter
pour venir vous solutionner votre vie au
quotidien à la maison et ça c'est bien
vous me dire vous maintenant ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaires si vous
intéresse mais évidemment je vous ai mis
un lien en bas dans la description des
luttes à venir cliquez dessus à
découvrir
et si vous cherchez un aspirateur robot
collectés pour la maison celui ci
pourrait bien faire les affaires dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaires contre on se retrouve très
vite beaucoup d'amour des gros coeur
prenez soin de vous et à bientôt
tél